so over that under aim to the center
okay so the problem is that our art is
external
working on his lives and you're trying
to get vocals token some levers through
his skeletal system okay but that's
going to require a force output capable
of what existence but there's no
guarantee you can generate enough energy
or force to do that and also fulcrums
and levers move and you can easily lose
your mechanical advantage does that make
sense so I don't want a technique that
has such a finite chemical advantage and
such a dubious one so we're going to
find another way of doing this and it's
how I aim to the center so we were
working with meteorite and you'll see
like you guys want to reach over and you
get these kind of cranks like that but
this this is enough to aim for him to
aim them so we want to get there okay so
we don't so we're not just cranking on
joints with stronger people and braver
people just override okay so we have to
know what we are feeling for that's the
problem is I can tell you to do it you
can see it you can feel it but when you
try to do it you think
and through skeletal tokens and lepers
okay so the first drill is I don't want
you to think of the goal I'm going to
give you I want you to try to understand
what it feels like so he's helping me
gain an awareness of the feeling so he
is pushing and I should feel a pressure
as I maintain my position okay and I'm
not here I'm just not caving it so he
will slowly generate it and I almost
feel that pressure start to fill me up
what I'm doing is the same grounding
drill I'm taking this energy and aiming
it in the ground but that's not my goal
I'm doing that to generate a sensation
of de pressure do you understand so if I
if for example if I don't ground it
pressure is in my back it's not filling
me up and that's the wrong sensation so
I use the ground vector in the ground
path to generate this nonlocalized
pressure that goes through my entire
body
so you can keep pushing and I am now I
can leave the ground pop and just hold
the pressure I can feel my stomach start
to swell you should be able to see it as
I'm leaving the ground pop then I hand
this is for you I'm going to release
tension as it had nothing to do with the
pressure and you will feel yourself sink
in more you feel it in the chest
and I
somehow stabilized and he is really blue
to me okay you might not get that far
you might go here he pushes and you
might holy cow okay try the ground puff
okay and then have your partner so he's
gonna aim it down and have your partner
help you by sensing for example let's
say I push I do that you see so I would
feel that about to happen so I will
decrease do you see
decrease and allow him time to get back
to where he wants to be needs to be
because I want him to feel the pressure
of the connection
okay let's try it okay Taylor
so as I generate this pressure you don't
want to waste 50% of your training time
so you as you go ahead and do it right
you should be able to start to feel the
pressure to okay and you I want you to
feel for that you can you might have to
increase keep feeling keep feeling and
now leave it on don't take it off even
if as you start to move do you
understand that keep this same feeling
okay now I'm going to take the pressure
and task myself with moving without
shutting off the feeling and you will be
moved as you get and task yourself with
being moved without shutting off the
feeling okay the movement makes it
difficult and gets a respond a more
refined skill but when we have the
pressure and you feel the pressure we
are connected okay so I'm going to move
without shutting off the pressure and
you will be moved without
it's a very simple thing don't don't
make it complicated she generates it and
then you'll feel that you have feel for
the sensation just like I'm touching you
here and you feel for that touch you
feel for the pressure and then I tasked
myself with moving and she tasks
yourself with being moved so if see how
it got disconnected no you're fine I
just want you to feel the difference do
you think okay I'm here and I gender
that the pressure start to swell I go
through the relaxation I want you to
feel this you'll sink in you see okay
and now we're really glued so don't be
afraid as I move you keep the sensation
[Music]
so even if I you go we generate the
pressure
I let the release there it is
did you see it even steals your breath
okay it doesn't matter whether I go slow
I'll go slow and we'll keep the pressure
pressure pressure pressure you see it's
coming back and the pressure and the
pressure and you see your stance is
getting lighter pressure
sensation yeah okay now there's no
reason other than a psychological one of
why it has to change when I go fast okay
pressure and you keep the feeling there
is no other reason to sight except for
the psychological one why I can't do it
upon you understand
okay so you got play with it you can
keep it slow because a lot of times if
we start to lose it when we when we try
to go so I can go slow
you can let it gradually get pressure
and then move it or you can just you see
that okay each one is a little more
difficult isn't it right okay okay so as
as we try to do this we get tasked with
this results and didn't want you to do
that your focus is the pressure between
the two of you not her falling okay so
as you make the mistake and task
yourself but we're falling that's where
we see this stuff so you go in here like
that
no we're gonna increase the pressure
just like I said it's a sensation I can
feel it and now I'm going to move
without losing the feeling so when I
turn like that it goes off do you see
that that's when I lose connection
that's where I don't have their Center
and actually they have the initiative
okay so I have the feeling and keeping
the feeling tells me where I need to go
so she is again Lucas on the inside of
the feeling so she keeps the feeling
and I could move this feeling anywhere
they get go counterclockwise
I can go clock wise and we don't lose
the feeling
keep your feeling again I don't even
need good posture to keep the feeling do
you see I don't even need face to keep
the feeling I can move and we will be
here so even suit ndin techniques have
this same feeling you see this is not
right that's not so heavy
okay so I am generate so let's try
without the throw and let's do this
counterclockwise and then a clockwise
and again will not shut off the pressure
okay let's try to take the throw out so
we're not so attempted God so but here
the feeling the pressure feeling and
pressure is a poetic
it's not just what it feels like
okay
it's just to paya might be a big sense
today maybe it does maybe I change
somewhere tomorrow okay so here the
pressure was generated this way okay
we're gonna generate the pressure this
way okay
let's generate it this way it's no
differences that's my shoulder
that's his arm he pushes and I let the
pressure if I push here I filled it here
I don't feel the pressure here so he
goes and I just increase the pressure
and then once we both have it I do the
same movement drill let's do the first
one he keeps it and I am not moving to
throw him not moving to take them off
balance
I'm moving to maintain the pressure do
you understand that
okay so that's why I wouldn't go like
that that takes it off okay I'm here
like that generate the pressure and then
we're I'm gonna task myself with moving
it he's gonna task himself with keeping
it as he gets moved so I started
you may ask yourself I noticed a turn at
the end what is the difference between
that turn at the end and this turn well
he is falling to one side that's where
the pressure is going do you understand
so as we go this way he's gonna start to
go that way in order to keep the pili I
have to start the turn you see that if
he's going that way and I keep pushing
straight let's exaggerated it goes off
do you see goes off so I'm not turning
it like you might think like that I am
keeping the sensation as long as
possible I can feel it starting to go
off so I have to turn them to keep it do
you understand okay so I'm here and
again you can do the same thing
you can't go slow
you can slowly generate it got it and
then BOOM oh I can't do it on the touch
okay let's go so this is the only
difference between a gradual pressure
and the slow projection or a gradual
pressure and a quick projection or
projection immediately on contact
it's just psychological okay
mechanically physiological is to say
well same thing here the only difference
between this pressure and this pressure
is psychological okay so when we go to
katatetori
it's psychological you have to stop
yourself from doing skeletal alignment
do you see that that's why we started
with this okay so even though my arm is
extended at the close-quarter combat
range it's not a skeletal alignment do
you understand that it's pressure
generated so just like push this is
wrong this is wrong you see it's the
same use of generating the pressure okay
so keep going and you can you'll feel
that I can keep my shape of my hand but
internally you're gonna see what I miss
you already
because I really see that isolated
flexion and just focusing in on the
pressure okay and then I keep that
pressure so let's start right there
drilling the other thing because the
skeletal alignment and the isolating
flexion has nothing to do with the
pressure okay but I don't want if I if I
see you this do you see that is because
I am trying not to have my forearm
collapsing you squeeze my tendons it
does that but there's nothing there
there's nothing it's just you keep
trying with that part it's just mushy
mushy all the way is just not going to
go anywhere but I feel the push okay and
you can hear it in my voice there's no
tension in my voice it's just as much as
this hand is out this hand is out now I
keep the feeling and I move it I can do
the circle again
or is that
okay the reason why I mentioned this is
because you already have a physiological
past a skeletal and isolated flexion do
you see and we want to know and take
what we did in the last row and change
our concept of katatetori okay I'm
changing it instead I'm using this to
feel the pressure feel the pressure and
then I ask myself but moving without
going back to this
I'm just here and I keep the pressure
and you test yourself with being moved
and you keep the pressure so again watch
I'm gonna shut it off you'll feel it
you see cuz I wasn't pushing into it I
keep the pressure
got it okay try it you always feel like
crowd noise but like that that's why
you're so Kentucky Dodie it's some way
looks easier because I can use my pecs
and get you to go but in other ways it's
harder precisely because I can use my
pecs you see that okay so remember the
guidelines I gave you so I have pressure
then releasing okay it's not releasing
the vaccine and then I try to get
pressure that your balloon is but on the
airs coming out so she grabs if she
grabs really hard and I'm relaxed you
can see what she's doing to my fingers
you see that but if I let the pressure
go she can't she can't close them but
it's mushy okay and now I just now I
would relax now I keep going and it'll
let the pressure keep expanding okay and
as the pressure expands you get spot to
me it's easy it's easier with small
movements to move you do see the small
movements if I go stiff right that goes
here but if I start relaxing let the
pressure go small movements move you
okay do you guys got that so we're using
the hand not caving in as a symptom to
note that I did follow the order
pressure then releasing acceptance
relaxation okay it's all again is
psychological so the mind is faster than
you can do this you
so when she begins to touch there's
already pressure and I've already
released do you see so but you can go
slow in the drill you could start tense
okay get a pressure feeling and then
release but you're moving at the speed
of mind it happens in an instant okay
that the whole pressure and releasing on
it okay let's try it
okay so again where you touch is just a
psychological difference so as I go to
grab as you kick I should be able to do
the same thing as you can
so I generate the pressure through my
own agency to see and then I can make
the center loop we have Center
engagement and I can make the center
move in the same way do you understand
me so I go here I will generate the
pressure that's what I was doing for him
in the other drill well that generated
pressure for me and as much as he's
connected to me I am connected to him
but now I'm going to be the agent so
don't lose this and don't start doing
that feel the pressure and move the
pressure to keep it
and again you can do this gradual like
that you can find it and move it a
little quicker and you can't do it on
touch point you got it okay after you
getting it take the next step
your fingers have nothing to do with it
okay so I can open my palm and I
generate the pressure at my club and I
can project that in tune so again it's
not that I'm grabbing here and then
you're like you're slipping up his arm
you're just here okay feel the pressure
and then keep that and task myself with
moving
he tasks himself with being moved so
although you can normally graphs in this
case and Nagas good
okay let's go I saw you you're trying to
open your breath okay so look look at my
girl and you'll feel the pressure
increase you see my good weight pay
attention don't shut off the pressure
don't shut it off
[Music]
what's the difference you're trying to
do a little look okay
and then sometimes you would use the
push of your webbing you see that okay
so it's the pressure you feel the
pressure increasing okay so pressure is
increasing and pressure pressure
pressure okay
it's not it's not the external ledge you
see even when it is an external ledge
it's the pressure that I'm doing okay so
all I'm demonstrating is that there's no
ledge do you see
but I'm demonstrating to say like
increasing the pressure is increasing
and then once once once I have this
connection right you can you see I keep
that connection
I'll see you like a good this is a
stupid trick but it was kind of hard for
me okay but see how I'm slipping yes I
that's because I can't do it internally
enough okay so let's go back to mine
here and now I have the friction because
I have the pressure okay and then okay
so if you're going to open your grip
actually open your grip don't don't
trick like that okay but in the same way
that katate dori was actually harder for
us because it was so easy to do external
then the same thing is
this is harder for us because it's so
easy to do the external edges okay all
right
again psychologically there is no
difference between two hands touching
you anywhere okay so how you'll feel the
pressure feeling you see I feel the
pressure feeling and I'm not squeezing
you to get friction I just have two
points of contact okay two points of
contact here it goes there's the
pressure it's going on right and then I
can move you okay so that's just for now
do it here like okay and here we go okay
and then one side we have it and then I
tasked myself with moving it and you
test yourself with not shutting it off
oh and do it right on the touch you can
go slow if you want gradually increase
it again it's not that is it just
feeling that pressure and then when you
have it you can gradually or again I'm
not doing this it's not that elbow
fulcrum it's just this it's nothing more
than the pressure and the connection I
just I'm touching you here everything
else is just a psychological difference
okay let's try it
so we're gonna do what you think is a
pain compliance technique but I'm not
gonna actually put all the elements in
there so before I had two points of
contact here and generate the pressure
again and then I just aim it through
there so I'm not torquing anything I'm
just touch of them here touch it in here
I'm closer to the technique do you see
then there generate depression if I go
like this see it's not there it's gotta
go up his arm you can go slow just keep
feeling for the pressure and you're
moving it
and of course you can go on contact okay
okay just lie Kotaku daughter was harder
because it looks like something else and
just like when you grabbed him it look
like something else right and just like
when I told you to open your ribbon look
like some pledges alright this looks
like a pain compliance technique do you
see that so we'll get it get it in place
but I'm not gonna go external it's gonna
go into his body it's the same exact
thing so right now I'm just moving it in
the same pattern that I had before I
want you to have the lock in place and
not start tweaking things just feel the
connection even those arms bent you're
not going this way your feeling for the
connection so my grips are the grips of
Mikio my elbows need y'all I'm in Kisa
but I feel the pressure and I do another
pressure drill closer to the technique
home again you can do it slow you can
enjoy it in circles if you want you can
do circles keeping the pressure you can
do it on touch okay let's go okay so
your life well I had that our arms so
that's like a Ledge you see that there
you go like you have this and then
you're using this arm
push that arm but what people do is that
you go around you go around nursing the
energy actually has to go up it has to
go up so I again it's not fear that I'm
doing it that's why you can open your
grip right and I'm going around so watch
me go around your elbow you see that's
the obvious one right I'm going to go
through your elbow see that so even
though as I have my grips here I still
need to not shut it off
it goes around it's in and pressures
just increasing okay so what I this is
just for demonstration I want you to to
try to decrease the pressure that I'm
sending up your elbow what do you feel
me doing okay where do you feel like
going so you're gonna take it off your
elbow and I'm gonna nothing you're gonna
see that it doesn't go up okay so let's
start over
pressure and then you take it off your
elbow do you think it's still there do
you see how I'm doing that okay guys
people counter alright okay so
watch your ledges I can keep my grip
it's the same thing it's the same exact
thing same exact thing
should feel the same way okay let's move
on so psychologically what we were doing
here is that she's given me her Center
right and I am simply maintaining that
relationship well as you gave me your
Center I manipulated your Center this
time I'm just going to manipulate your
Center very much like
in that last demonstration as you
counter I kept making it work because I
kept aiming it through your Center okay
so I she gave me in her Center last time
the path that I took was mainly one of
just pushing into her okay but I still
felt the pressure I still felt her
Center I don't have to take that power I
could take any path that Ames endeavour
Center okay so here is an arm one and
then I will do the same thing aiming
into Center
you see that difference so an arm one
and I aim it into her Center does she's
try to counter it
I want to show you that see if you can
see the difference when I do the hard
one look where her body her body goes
watch your center now what do you feel
you got light and look at your knees
do you see your knees watch the watch
your knees now push watch your knees now
okay watch your knees now you see so I'm
gonna throw your Center I am NOT making
your wrists her and you move your stuff
do you see that go ahead and move you
see that difference I am throwing her
Center not in ledges right but through
manipulation and there's no need for
torquing my hands just hold here contact
will throw the center if I if I am
torque really dependent then I must be
stronger than you okay
there's no torque it's just Center
connection every time
again I'll show you you you won't like
this properly again so I go really slow
so you can feel it you feel it there's
your Center
okay watch I don't get don't puss out
okay okay try okay just like in the same
way when we were doing these drills and
it looked like I was turning and I told
you I'm not turning I'm keeping the
pressure he turned so that's why I'm
following the pressure okay
same things happening in here so you're
like I'm gonna get his elbow to go like
that do you see that but that's actually
not your Center
it is an external angle constellation
but it is not the center manipulation so
your your elbow will go down like that
but it's not it's incidental to the to
the center connection to see Center
connection center connection and then I
move that elbow down with the center
connection it's not I did the elbow
right on and then that guy goes out and
goes out there you see that so I the
angle is just incidental to what I want
combative Lee in the larger scale but
the concept of it should still aim in
your Center guys got that again so don't
over rely on the angle cancellation on
the elbow because that's an external
focal lever okay use that elbow point in
is just another vector for Center
connection for pressure but there should
be a projection unless there's a
projection
you can watch sometimes pocket and in
this light we're not moving
but if you watch you can you can tell
how much energy there's actually hit the
chicken
[Music]